[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour suivre l'actualité locale
voici les titres de ce jeudi 12 novembre
1 millions de français auraient basculé
dans la pauvreté avec la crise sanitaire
c'est le chiffre avancé par plusieurs
associations caritatives des difficultés
que ressent déjà certains yvelinois nous
avons subi une marotte de la protection
civile et nous recevons le président des
restos du coeur du département saint
quentin en yvelines repensa collecte des
déchets les consignes de tri ne change
pas mais l'organisation va être modifié
avec pour but de réduire l'impact sur
l'environnement et traiter plus
efficacement un cd chez elles les auto
écoles sont fermés mais les examens du
permis de conduire sont eux maintenus
contrat mon premier confinement une
situation plutôt délicate pour certains
candidats privés de cours de conduite
[Musique]
composé de 80 bénévoles la protection
civile des yvelines organise des
maraudes pour venir en aide à la
population
au programme distribution de repas
chauds et suivi psychologique
mardi 10 octobre grégory canale et
justine de brasiers ont suivi l'équipe
en charge de la soirée regarder on est
prêt pour le départ pour la maraude
oui tout à fait et bien c'est parfait
allons-y je t'écoute pour l'adresse
c'est nom du bénéficiaire et des secours
il est fort mais voilà la devise de la
protection civile
parmi les missions de l'association les
maraudes samu social
objectif sortir les bénéficiaires de la
rue
le rôle des bénévoles a mené une aide
matérielle et alimentaires mais aussi et
surtout apporter une aide psychologique
et effectuer un suivi du bénéficiaire
on discute on pas ça qu'on crée du lien
et ça c'est même parfois presque plus
important que la nourriture était là
depuis combien de temps ici je suis sage
en trois mois trois semaines du coup a
du coup avant tu es tu étais où d'accord
l'équipe part à la rencontre des
bénéficiaires dans la rue des personnes
qui ont demandé une aide ou des
personnes croisées au fil de la soirée
elle leur procure kits d'hygiène
couverture café ou encore repas chauds
et font remonter leurs besoins ce qui
est important dans les maraudes c'est la
circulation d'informations c'est pas
juste d'aller donner un café mais c'est
que ses informations remontent au niveau
de la direction départementale de la
cohésion sociale et de l'ensemble des
services pour pouvoir trouver les
solutions pérennes à ces personnes ce
que j'ai noté par rapport à tes besoins
de couverture et où je le rappelais la
réunion pour la prochaine marée haute
je vais demander ce qui t'amène quelque
chose un seul mot d'ordre adaptation les
bénévoles doivent répondre aux demandes
qui arrive la régulation reste en
contact avec l'équipe du début à la fin
de la maraude
quand on part on
on sait l'endroit on sait le ou les
personnes mais on sait pas forcément
quand la personne a appelé et on ne sait
pas forcément ce qu elle va avoir besoin
en terme de nourriture en terme de deux
kits d'hygiène là on devait faire une
maraude se pressent eu là une mission
qui tombe on a bien fait de rappeler la
réguler
donc on y va on va voir ce que ce qu'on
va trouver en 2019 les maraudes de la
protection civile avait permis de
rencontrer près de 200 personnes
une aide précieuse pour ces personnes
sans domicile fixe tant mieux que ça
existe il ya beaucoup de beaucoup de
monde qui sont encore dehors c'est la
nuit il n'y a pas valu ya pas beaucoup
de monde il ya plutôt des fous tu passes
on les connaît pas trop c'est dangereux
cobra peu quand on vous voit mason
réconfort c'est très difficile surtout
en ce moment avec le confinement et tout
le bordel là c'est vraiment difficile
franchement moi je suis heureux car à
moins que sont l'or le premier
confinement c'était dur parce que ils
étaient pas il n'était pas là il n'était
pas là les jeux d confiné une maraude et
organisés chaque semaine un nombre qui
pourrait s'intensifier sur la période
hivernale
une double peine pour les populations
défavorisées lakovic 19 les touches sur
le plan sanitaire mais aussi sur le plan
social
je vous le disais dans les titres selon
plusieurs associations 1 millions de
français auraient basculé dans la
pauvreté nous a rejoint en plateau
emmanuel nodé langlois bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le président des restos du
coeur et des yvelines vous le voyez
aussi dans les yvelines cette situation
alors on commence à le sentir très
visiblement depuis le mois de septembre
c'est à dire que les statistiques on
avait pu sortir au moment du confinement
avant les vacances ne sont pas
significatifs dans la maison on a été
obligé d'arrêter complètement notre
activité par contre depuis le depuis
début septembre on voit que il ya une
montée hélas en puissance du nombre de
personnes que nous accueillons à tel
point qu'aujourd'hui dans certains
centres des yvelines ça devient très
problématique notamment à plaisir où on
a plus 70% aux mureaux on est à + 43 %
et puis dans un sa tendance au moment de
la ville 18% et rambouillet 24%
qu'est ce qui explique certains sites
soit plus touchés que d'autres certaines
villes alors ce soir je suis j'ai très
fort je suis dans la capacité de vous
répondre
par contre on est en train de de
d'étudier assez précisément la question
je pense qu'il ya certains sens qui sont
plus touchés que d'autres parce que il
ya des hôtels du 115 qui sont pas loin
et automatiquement ça draine un certain
nombre de personnes
qui donne directement tourner au centre
lors selon un sondage réalisé par
l'institut ipsos 33% des personnes
interrogées disent avoir touché moins
d'argent entre le début de l'année 2020
et le mois d'août est ce que c'est le
cas de certains de vos bénéficiaires
alors aujourd'hui je serais venu dans
dix jours j'aurais peut-être pu répondre
à cette question je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que on est rentré dans la
période de des nouvelles inscriptions
chaque année on refait le point avec les
familles savaient pas parce qu'ils me
fahmi a étaient inscrites aux restos du
coeur qu'elles peuvent venir tous les
ans sans aucun problème donc là on est
en plein d'inscriptions on est en train
de refaire le point et on aura plus de
précisions sur je dirais le nouveau type
de famille que l'on va accueillir d'ores
et déjà ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que on l'a plus de retraités il ya plus
d'étudiants
il ya des sdf qu'on ne voyait pas trop
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est évident je
pense que la typologie des gens va
changer justement aussi est-ce qu'ils
sont arrivés dans une situation il ne se
ressent plus ils ne s'en sortent plus du
tout ils font le pas d'aller le voir ce
qu'il n'aurait pas fait peut-être hors
cause et 19 je pense que c'est tout à
fait vrai à tel point que l'on revoit
des familles que l'on ne voyait plus
depuis deux trois ans et qui l'a sont
obligés de revenir de faire le pas de
franchir la porte des restos du coeur
parce qu'ils n'y arrivent plus je pense
que le pic pour nous va être au mois de
janvier au mois de février parce que à
certains de personnes vont sortir deux
de leurs droits sociaux de l'heure de la
protection et je pense que le mois de
janvier février va être assez difficile
et justement ces gens là viennent
chercher une aide alimentaire
principalement une lettre nettes de
logements de conseil
alors les restos du coeur nous sommes
connus pour l'aide alimentaire
donc là à très court terme on va se
focaliser sur l'aide alimentaire
il est vrai que les restos du coeur dans
les yvelines
il y a on n'a que quinze mille personnes
donc c'est ce n'est pas négligeable dans
26 ans est donc aujourd'hui on met la
priorité sur l'alimentaire mais on a
pleins d'eau des activités est ce qu'on
appelle de l'aide à la personne alors
sap et du juridique on aide
on apprend le français à des gens
l'informatique de la recherche d'emploi
donc c'est assez vaste pour le moment la
priorité c'est de donner à manger aux
gens une crise qui touche aussi
l'organisation même de votre antenne va
bénévoles seulement et settat et c'est
un gros problème et journée c'est de me
poser la question parce que juste avant
début septembre et fait un recensement
au niveau des 26 centre des yvelines
pour savoir ce qu'on met bénévole je
pouvais compter et j'ai eu le résultat
la semaine dernière et on est à -25% en
termes de bénévoles alors je ne leur
jette pas la pierre c'est évident la
santé des bénévoles prime avant tout
mais ça va être un réel problème là pour
les bénévoles qui seraient intéressés
les nouveaux bénévoles qui seraient
intéressés de venir nous rejoindre si je
peux les rassurer on a mis tout en
oeuvre pour sécuriser l'accueil des
personnes on est on suit les règles
sanitaires qui nous sont imposées par
les pouvoirs publics
il ya aucun problème j'ai même un
monsieur hygiène et sécurité donc on a
mis des choses en place et je pense que
si on peut rassurer les les bénévoles
potentiels je pense que ça soit bien
voilà j'espère que le message est passé
merci manuel nodé langlois d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
la campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
va bientôt commencer ce que vous pouvez
nous rappeler la dette
elle va commencer le 24 novembre c'est à
dire dans 12 jours et le site de votre
antenne c'est aussi affichés à l'antenne
pour ceux qui cherchent les absolutions
supplémentaires merci 9
[Musique]
avec le deuxième confinement les
entreprises cherchent à innover deux
d'entre elles installées à buc ont
délaissé impression numérique et
douceurs sucrées pour se lancer dans la
livraison maraîchère la cage est
solidaire livre sur une quinzaine de
communes yvelinoise essonnienne gregory
kane allez je vous ai mis la voilà la
composition de la cagette avec la
provenance est une idée recette pour
cette semaine m
12 références de fruits et légumes
parcage est 100 kg qui sont directement
livrés à domicile
marie va est l'une des clients de la
cage est solidaire une toute jeune
entreprise
je suis pour acheter mes fruits et
légumes chez des commerçants plutôt qu
en grande surface parce que nos niveaux
bout ça change totalement et surtout en
ce moment il faut faut soutenir les
commerces la cage est solidaire est le
fruit d'une fusion temporaire celle de
deux entreprises bucs oise elle est née
sept
hélas cette vision depuis deux semaines
raf koussa a délaissé le caramel pour
devenir livreur on s'approvisionne
majoritairement chez des producteurs
locaux et dans un souci de diversité
on ne va chercher nos produits ailleurs
en france et certains produits à
l'étranger comme l'ananas ou ou les
haricots verts en ce moment on a l'amour
des bons produits du bien manger et on a
le ona les équipements on a le matériel
on a nos camions on a une chambre froide
qui nous faire déjà une initiative
qu'ils espèrent poursuivre avec des
compositions personnalisées la cagette a
livré 150 clients depuis son lancement
la décision a été rendue aujourd'hui la
demande de requalification d'un viol
dans la sphère des trois pompiers
poursuivis a été rejeté ce jeudi par la
cour d'appel de versailles en novembre
2018 le parquet avait renvoyé les trois
hommes devant le tribunal correctionnel
pour atteintes sexuelles sur mineurs ils
sont poursuivis pour des faits commis
sur julie âgée de 14 ans au début des
faits entre 2009 et 2011 et ils
s'estiment oubliés
déconsidéré et appelle diverses
personnalités politiques à les aider les
agents du centre hospitalier de plaisir
ont adressé une lettre pour obtenir eux
aussi la revalorisation salariale
annoncée lors du ségur de la santé il
envisage une manifestation
l'intersyndicale fo cgt et sud dénombre
entre 350 et 400 agents concernés le
centre hospitalier de plaisir est
spécialisé dans la gériatrie la prise en
charge de la maladie mentale et le
médico social à partir du 4 janvier 2000
à 21 l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines améliore son réseau de collecte
de déchets c'est à l'entreprise c'est
pure qu'elle en a confié la charge les
consignes de tri restent les mêmes mais
une nouvelle organisation va être
instaurée pour harmoniser et optimiser
les collectes sur le territoire réduire
l'impact sur l'environnement et traiter
plus efficacement les déchets sont les
deux principaux objectifs
on écoute les précisions de jean marie
jean michel chevallier conseiller
communautaire délégué à la collecte et à
la valorisation des déchets il est
interviewé par lots nord sino qu'est ce
qui va changer évidemment pour eux pour
les saint quentinois ce sont les rythmes
de collecte et les fréquences de
collecte
je prends l'exemple par exemple des
ordures ménagères a effectivement
aujourd'hui en pavillonnaire on passait
deux fois par semaine à l'avenir en 2021
on ne passera plus qu'une fois par
semaine
[Musique]
on est dans le cadre de la loi de
transition énergétique de 2015 et cette
loi impose aux collectivités de réduire
de 50 % le volume de déchets admis en
site de stockage d'ici 2025
on est en 2020 bientôt 2021 et notre
nouveau marché démarre en 2021 2025
c'est demain hein donc 50 % de réduction
c'est une contrainte forte on a fait le
choix à saint-quentin-en-yvelines de
transformer cette contrainte en enjeu un
enjeu environnemental
depuis qu'on a commencé à communiquer
sur les nouveaux marchés
il ya beaucoup d'un qui se lève et de
gens qui nous disent mais vous vous
rendez pas compte c'est aberrant on n'y
arrivera jamais ce n'est pas possible
alors voilà effectivement la première
démarche de saint quentin a été celle de
dire il faut qu on impulse
cette dynamique de changement de
fondement de nous penser qu'on va
arriver à produire moins
si on collecte différemment on va
forcément obligé les saint quentinois a
résonné peut-être différemment les auto
écoles sont fermées depuis leur
confinement et pourtant les examens ont
permis conduire ne sont pas annulés et
des candidats sont prévus pour tout le
mois de novembre
une situation plutôt perturbante pour
ces candidats un sujet de bixente mairie
insisté ban et patrick jacques de
dixmude
si vous avez croisé une de ses voitures
dans la rue c'était un examen au permis
de conduire
les sessions sont maintenues même si les
auto écoles sont fermées ne peuvent plus
dispensés de cours en fait au moment où
j'ai voulu reprendre des heures bayel
confinement qui est tombé donc j'ai dû
revenir à l'examen sans nous préparer au
préalable nous partons en examen là ce
matin on a rendez-vous à 10h et on a
quatre candidats à présenter donc on a
des candidats qui n'ont pas conduit
depuis
un mois et demi deux mois pour certains
une situation délicate pour certains qui
se confrontent à l'inspecteur sans se
sentir vraiment prêt j'étais très
stressé dans la voiture et je pense que
ça s'est vu que j'avais pas conduit
depuis un moment donc
alors moi j'ai de la chance parce que je
suis reconduit de surprise et donc j'ai
pu conduire avec ma famille récemment
donc dernière fois que j'ai pu conduire
c'était il ya une semaine et demie de
semaine c'est quand même assez léger
comme entraînement donc c'est pour ça
que j'étais chanceux d'avoir un rendez
vous assez tôt pour éviter de perdre un
peu encore plus la main pour pour
l'examen les épreuves sont maintenues
pour désengorger au maximum les deux
mondes
certains élèves attendre leur session
depuis plusieurs semaines le bouchon qui
s'est créé sur le premier confinement
c'est surtout ça qui coince donc l'idée
c'est de
maintenir les examens pour pas accentuer
le problème de files d'attentes pour les
délais de présentation
je pense qu'ils annuleront pas c'est ça
le plus le mois de novembre avancent
plus le temps est long entre un candidat
et sa dernière heure de conduite
c'est pourquoi les taux de réussite des
écoles ne devraient pas être prises en
compte pendant la période
ce deuxième confinement touche bien sûr
le monde de la culture comme la
compagnie les tisseurs de songes elle
les artistes étaient en résidence en
cours de création pour un spectacle
prévu en décembre
le lieu ayant fermé à cause du
confinement il se retrouve à l'arrêt
malgré l'autorisation du gouvernement de
poursuivre la préparation de ce
spectacle justin brasier a échangé avec
kenan des salles dé l'air le directeur
artistique de la compagnie pour
connaître son ressenti sur ce deuxième
confinement je suis pas persuadé que
c'est il faut leur bon sens là puisque
la culture assure aussi un lien social
elle assure beaucoup de choses et puis
l'ouverture d'esprit tolérance etc
donc oui c'est très très compliqué en ce
moment
qu'une production de spectacles ça se
normalement ça se pense au moins sur
deux ans le temps de faire les budgets
les demandes de subventions de recherche
de coproduction ou de co réalisation de
salles
là on est plutôt sur du 3 ans minimum je
fais déjà tous les spectacles du premier
confinement comptait reporter son
bouquet est un peu les programmations et
les salles aujourd'hui se retrouvent en
plus emmener dans des considérations
terrible le travail je pense ne sera
jamais fait pour rien pour l'utiliser
d'une manière ou d'une autre
maintenant il faut réussira à passer le
cap et se dire que oui on crée quelque
chose en ce moment mais que si ça se
trouve demande jouera à eux donc je vois
après demain non plus peut-être que ce
sera pas dans un an ou dans deux
peut-être dirigea aussi vers des
spectacles de rue et puis des formes
déambulatoire des formes en plein air en
tout cas qui devrait être plus facile à
mettre en place
on espère il n'y a plus de poilus à
adopter les quelques deux cent trente
sept mille fiche matricules des soldats
de la guerre 14-18 conservés aux
archives départementales des yvelines
ont été référencés par des volontaires
lancé en 2016 le projet avait pour but
de mettre à disposition les données
collectées aux internautes cherchent
associations ou encore généalogistes
elles seront aussi transmises à la
plateforme le grand mémorial le portail
du ministère de la culture et de la
communication ce deuxième confinement
c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir des
nouveaux jeux sur sino le chasseur de
trésor est un nouveau jeu de société
disponible depuis le 1er novembre
il met en lumière de façon ludique le
patrimoine yvelinois célia catherine
gaud faire découvrir le patrimoine des
yvelines tout en s'amusant c'est le
concept de la société familiale créée à
club games
depuis le 1er novembre une nouvelle
édition yvelinoise de cire sino le
chasseur de trésor est disponible en
vente dans les magasins du département
thouaré guyancourt trappe ou encore
château ce sont 36 communes sur 262 qui
ont été retenus pour ce jeu on a demandé
au conseil départemental de choisir 12
franceagrimer à sion 12 moyennes et 12
petits villages de manière à ce que
voilà chacun puisse s'identifier
ce matin là les créateurs de sursis nous
ont fait découvrir leurs jeux aux
enfants du centre aéré de maisons
laffitte
c'est un peu difficile de trouver à les
bonnes pièces d'or et à tous et métissée
est difficile de retourner au monde
ce jeu de société et au prix de 24 euros
95 et se joue de deux à quatre joueurs
sur chinois pour vocation d'être une
chasse au trésor dans le département
mais sans questions sans connaissance
particulière sans compétence
particulière
l'idée c'est vraiment de découvrir en
s'amusant et des six ans mais aussi de
faire plaisir à mamie donc d'être un jeu
intergénérationnel
le principe chaque commune à une carte
individuelle sur celle ci se trouve un
petit élément
cet élément est également sous forme de
pièces d'or cachés dans des coffres
le but retrouvez ces pièces le plus vite
possible pour gagner la partie par
toujours du principe que le dernier de
la classe unique est en difficulté à
l'école doit pouvoir battre le premier
de la classe
parce que jouer ça à un moment où lui
doivent doit pas être en échec la
société kraken games est en train
d'élaborer un nouveau jeu de société sur
le patrimoine de la france qui sortira
pour noël 2021 un sujet que vous pouvez
retrouver dans notre émission spéciale
re confinement si on rentrait présenté
par wilfrid richy au programme de ce
numéro musique non gars et sport et
c'est à découvrir juste après ce journal
qui se termine à présent merci de nous
avoir suivis vous pouvez revoir
l'émission et le reportage en replay sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]